les jeux vidéo sont partout surtout à
l'époque de noël à consommer sur place
ou à emporter à la maison mais pourtant
le bruit
voilà maintenant un jeu plus classique
de l'informatique mais tout à fait
remarquable parce qu'il intègre
énormément de choses
c'est jeu très mal c'était une série de
jeux on peut programmer là c'est un coup
du loup a sauté je doit accueillir avec
mon 1 arrive bol je suis avec toi je
change de jeu je retire le noeud cirque
et je mets la course de fous
la mâchoire et crispé le regard fixe les
gestes saccadés
les symptômes sont clairs le diagnostic
sans appel
ces enfants sont atteints d'un mal très
contemporain la passion des jeux vidéo
une enquête de la sofres réalisée auprès
de 250 enfants de 7 à 14 ans nous
apprend que la majorité d'entre eux est
m ainsi projetés dans un autre univers
surmonter les difficultés et surtout
réalisé des performances toujours
supérieure on peut la voyez mon cheval
vient de percuter la barrière et
mentorat y courir faire sentir ses lots
il ya une espèce de compétition avec
soi-même ils veulent se vaincre même ils
veulent gagner ils veulent réussir et à
partir du moment où un enfant veut
réussir
évidemment il ya un dynamisme absolument
extraordinaires qui se fait qu existent
en lui et je trouve que c'est excellent
mais pour garder votre jeu et jouer plus
tard ou l'enregistrer sur une casse tout
à fait normal
après c'est vrai moi et alors ce post il
voulu garder on jouera après l'émission
ça c'est un rendez-vous et demain